"La felicidad es una elección que requiere esfuerzo".
Y la tercera, de Groucho Marx,
dice: "No elegiría pertenecer
a un club que me tuviese como miembro".
Ahora, las malas noticias:
No sabía cuál de estas citas
elegir para compartir con Uds.
La dulce angustia de la elección.
En el momento actual del capitalismo post-industrial,
la elección, la libertad individual
y la idea del hacerlo uno mismo,
se elevaron al estatus de ideal.
Además, tenemos la idea
del progreso infinito.
Pero como trasfondo de esta ideología
ha habido un aumento de la angustia,
del sentimiento de culpa,
de ser inadecuado,
de que fracasamos en nuestras elecciones.
Tristemente, esta ideología de la elección individual
nos ha impedido pensar los cambios sociales.
Aparentemente esta ideología fue en realidad
muy eficiente para pacificarnos
como pensadores políticos y sociales.
En vez de hacer críticas sociales,
nos autocriticamos cada vez más,
a veces hasta el punto de la autodestrucción.
Ahora, ¿por qué esta ideología de la elección
sigue siendo tan poderosa,
aún en personas que no tienen
muchas opciones para elegir?
¿Cómo es que incluso las personas pobres
todavía se identifican tanto con la idea de elección,
la idea racional de elección
que adoptamos nosotros?
La ideología de la elección es muy exitosa
para abrirnos un espacio de pensamiento
sobre futuros imaginados.
Les daré un ejemplo.
Mi amiga Manya,
cuando estudiaba en la universidad en California
ganaba dinero
trabajando en una concesionaria de autos.
Cuando Manya encontraba
al cliente típico, hablaba con él
sobre su estilo de vida,
cuánto quería gastar,
cuántos hijos tenía,
para qué necesitaba el auto.
Así llegaban a una buena conclusión
de cuál sería el auto perfecto.
Pero antes de que el cliente de Manya se fuese a casa
y pensara en lo hablado,
ella le decía:
"El auto que estás comprando es perfecto ahora
pero, en unos años,
cuando los niños se vayan de casa,
cuando tengas un poco más de dinero,
aquel otro auto será ideal.
Pero el que estás comprando ahora es genial".
La mayoría de los clientes de Manya
que volvían al día siguiente
compraban ese otro auto,
el que no necesitaban,
el que costaba muchísimo más.
Maya tuvo tanto éxito vendiendo autos
que pronto pasó a vender aviones.
(Risas)
Saber tanto sobre la psicología humana
la preparó bien para su empleo actual: es psicoanalista.
Pero ¿por qué los clientes de Manya eran tan irracionales?
El éxito de Manya consistía en poder
despertar en sus mentes la idea
de un futuro idealizado,
una imagen de ellos mismos
en la que ya son más exitosos, más libres,
y, para ellos, elegir ese otro auto
era como estar más cerca de este ideal
en el que Manya ya podía verlos.
Nunca elegimos de forma totalmente racional.
Nuestras elecciones están influenciadas por el inconsciente,
por nuestra comunidad.
A menudo elegimos
adivinando lo que pensarán otras personas
de nuestra elección.
También elegimos
mirando lo que eligen otros.
También adivinamos cuáles son las elecciones socialmente aceptables.
Es por eso en realidad
incluso después de haber elegido
comprar un auto,
leemos continuamente comentarios de autos,
como si siguiéramos queriendo convencernos
de que elegimos correctamente.
Las elecciones provocan ansiedad.
Están vinculadas al riesgo, a las pérdidas.
Son muy impredecibles.
Gracias a esto
las personas tienen ahora cada vez más problemas
con eso de no estar eligiendo nada.
No hace mucho, estaba en una boda
y conocía a una dama joven, hermosa,
que de inmediato empezó a contarme de su ansiedad por la elección.
Me dijo: "Necesito un mes
para decidir qué vestido ponerme".
Luego dijo: "Estuve investigando durante semanas
en qué hotel alojarme esta noche.
Y ahora tengo que elegir un donante de esperma".
(Risas)
Miré a esta mujer sobresaltada.
"¿Donante de esperma? ¿Cuál es el apuro?"
Dijo: "Cumpliré 40 a fin de año,
y he elegido muy mal a los hombres en mi vida".
La elección, por estar ligada al riesgo,
produce ansiedad
y fue el célebre
filósofo danés Søren Kierkegaard
que señaló que la ansiedad
está vinculada a la posibilidad de la posibilidad.
Hoy pensamos que esos riesgos se pueden prevenir.
Tenemos interminables análisis de mercado,
proyecciones de ingresos futuros.
Incluso en el mercado, que depende del azar,
que es aleatorio, pensamos que podemos predecir racionalmente
lo que ocurre.
La casualidad se está volviendo traumática.
El año pasado, mi amigo Bernard Harcourt
de la Universidad de Chicago organizó un evento,
una conferencia sobre la idea de causalidad.
Estábamos juntos en el panel,
y antes de presentar nuestros artículos
-- ninguno conocía el artículo del otro --
decidimos tomarnos la casualidad en serio.
Así, informamos al público
que lo que escucharían
sería un artículo al azar,
una mezcla de dos artículos
y que ninguno sabía lo que había escrito el otro.
De este modo dimos la conferencia.
Bernard leyó su primer párrafo,
yo leí mi primer párrafo,
Bernard leyó su segundo párrafo,
yo leí mi segundo párrafo,
y así hasta el final de nuestros artículos.
Les sorprenderá saber
que la mayoría de nuestro público
no creyó que estaban escuchando
un artículo totalmente aleatorio.
No podían creer
que viniendo de la posición de autoridad
que tenemos como profesores,
tomaríamos la casualidad seriamente.
Pensaron que preparamos los artículos juntos
y que simplemente estábamos bromeando con lo del azar.
Vivimos en una época de mucha información,
de "big data",
de mucho conocimiento del interior de nuestros cuerpos.
Decodificamos nuestro genoma.
Conocemos sobre nuestros cerebros mucho más que antes.
Pero, sorprendentemente, la gente cada vez más
hace la vista gorda frente a este conocimiento.
La ignorancia y la negación van en aumento.
Ahora, en cuanto a la crisis económica actual,
pensamos que despertaremos de nuevo
y todo será igual que antes,
que no necesitamos cambios políticos ni sociales.
En relación a la crisis ecológica,
pensamos que no es necesario hacer nada ahora,
o que otros tienen que actuar antes que nosotros.
Incluso cuando ocurre una crisis ecológica
como la catástrofe de Fukushima,
a menudo tenemos personas que viven en el mismo medioambiente
con la misma cantidad de información,
y la mitad de ellos estarán preocupados por la radiación
y la otra mitad la ignorará.
Los psicólogos saben muy bien
que las personas sorprendentemente no tenemos
pasión por el conocimiento
sino pasión por la ignorancia.
¿Qué quiere decir eso?
Digamos que cuando enfrentamos
una enfermedad que pone en riesgo la vida
muchas personas no quieren saberlo.
En vez de eso prefieren negar la enfermedad,
y por eso no es bueno informarles
si no preguntan.
Sorprende que la investigación muestre a veces
que las personas que niegan la enfermedad
viven más que las que eligen racionalmente
el mejor tratamiento.
Esta ignorancia, no obstante,
no es muy útil a nivel social.
Ignorar hacia dónde vamos
puede causar mucho daño social.
Por encima de la ignorancia
enfrentamos también hoy
cierto tipo de obviedad.
El filósofo francés
Louis Althusser señaló
que la ideología funciona en forma tal
que crea un velo de obviedad.
Antes de hacer cualquier crítica social
es necesario levantar el velo de la obviedad
y pensar en forma un poco diferente.
Si desandamos esta ideología
de la elección racional individual
que adoptamos a menudo,
es necesario precisamente aquí
levantar esta obviedad
y pensar de forma un poco diferente.
Para mí, la pregunta a menudo es:
¿por qué seguimos aferrados a esta idea del hombre que se hace a sí mismo,
que es la base del capitalismo desde su origen?
¿Por qué pensamos que tenemos tal maestría
sobre nuestras vidas que podemos, en forma racional,
hacer las mejores elecciones ideales
y no aceptamos pérdidas ni riesgos?
Me resulta muy impactante ver a veces a personas muy pobres,
por ejemplo, que no apoyan la idea
de que los ricos paguen más impuestos.
Muy a menudo, aquí todavía se identifican
con cierto tipo de mentalidad de lotería.
Quizá no piensen que les tocará a ellos en el futuro,
pero quizá mi hijo podría ser el próximo Bill Gates.
Y ¿quién querría cobrarle impuestos a su hijo?
O la pregunta para mí es también:
¿por qué las personas que no tienen seguro médico
no aceptan la asistencia sanitaria universal?
A veces no la aceptan
por identificación con la idea de elección,
pero no tienen opciones para elegir.
Margaret Thatcher dijo célebremente
que no hay tal cosa llamada sociedad.
La sociedad no existe, hay solo individuos
y sus familias.
Tristemente, esta ideología todavía funciona muy bien
y por eso hay personas pobres que podrían sentir
vergüenza de su pobreza.
Podríamos sentirnos eternamente culpables
de no elegir correctamente,
y por eso es que no tenemos éxito.
Nos angustia no ser lo suficientemente buenos.
Por eso trabajamos tan arduamente
largas jornadas laborales
y de igual manera muchas horas rehaciéndonos.
Cuando decidir nos angustia,
a veces regalamos nuestro poder de decisión.
Nos identificamos con el gurú
que nos dice qué hacer,
con el terapeuta de autoayuda,
o aceptamos un líder totalitario
que parece no tener dudas sobre la elección,
que parece saber.
A menudo me preguntan:
"¿Qué aprendiste de estudiar la elección?"
Y hay un mensaje importante que aprendí.
Al pensar en las elecciones,
dejé de tomármelas tan en serio, en lo personal.
Primero, me di cuenta de que muchas de las elecciones que hago
no son racionales.
Están ligadas a mi inconsciente, a lo que otros están eligiendo,
o a elecciones socialmente aceptadas.
También adopto la idea
de que deberíamos trascender
la idea de elección individual,
que es muy importante para repensar las elecciones sociales,
dado que esta ideología de la elección individual nos ha pacificado.
En realidad nos impide pensar el cambio social.
Pasamos mucho tiempo eligiendo cosas para nosotros mismos
y apenas nos detenemos
en las elecciones en común que podemos hacer.
No deberíamos olvidar que la elección
siempre está ligada al cambio.
Podemos hacer elecciones individuales,
pero podemos hacer cambios sociales.
Podemos elegir tener más lobos.
Podemos elegir cambiar nuestro ambiente
para tener más abejas.
Podemos elegir tener diferentes agencias de calificación.
Podemos elegir controlar a las corporaciones
en vez de permitirles que nos controlen.
Tenemos una posibilidad de hacer cambios.
Empecé con una cita de Samuel Johnson,
que dijo que cuando elijas en la vida
no te olvides de vivir.
Para terminar, pueden ver
que podía elegir
una de tres citas
para empezar mi conferencia.
Tuve una elección,
como naciones, como personas,
también tenemos elecciones para repensar
en qué tipo de sociedad queremos vivir en el futuro.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)